[Music]
consumer debt jumped 52 billion in march
the largest
increase on record in california 91 of
consumer loans were made in 2020
were the buy now pay later loans wow 91
more than 40 percent of gen z consumers
will have used by now pay later by the
end of the year it's the highest of any
age group
and the and now those debts are going
bad so it is a
it is an interesting thing that is
happening in the world of the buy now
pay later yeah it's the after pays
the clarinet
i think known as zip now quad pay and uh
we covered this on the fine print
podcast that i did you've covered it on
your show we were just ahead of the
trends and we didn't even we were like
this is bad don't do buy now pay later
now mainstream media is going hey maybe
buy now pay later isn't helping people
wow
what a shock if you look at their
marketing i was reading another article
so this one's from nymag.com buy now pay
and pay and pay and pay later great
headline sf gate did another one on buy
now pay later and the marketing they
interviewed some of the people at these
companies some of the top executives who
are saying oh buy now pay later it's a
budgeting tool that's what it is oh how
funny yeah we're not in the lending
business we're helping people with their
budget creating freedom
because we can spread out their payments
month after month after month well we
were just talking about before the show
that that because it's four payments and
it's not five they can avoid regulation
that they can legally avoid regulation
whether it's the fees or the interest
rates and stuff they don't have to abide
uh yeah they don't have to be
transparent with the full cost of the
loan because they don't have to do that
until it's five payments so they get
around it by making it just for just
four payments but it is debt people wow
it is dead yeah this is exploding
especially with influencers on instagram
and tick tock we're seeing influencers
push this because guess what they're
getting a kickback from you using buy
now pay later the retailers are making
money you know they're making 45 percent
more on the average store order because
they have buying a pay later because it
is it's incredible what it does just to
your
your mental state when you are buying
online
and that comes up and says well instead
of a hundred dollars for this order you
could just pay 25. you're like oh just
25 free up money in your budget that
feels so much better and then you pay
for it the next month and then maybe you
forget the next month and then that's
when the fees kick in and the interest
and all of i mean it's just we're seeing
a lot of people miss payments because
everyone does it with great intentions
yes
that'll be fine i can pay it and then a
month gets tight and you don't have the
margin you don't have the extra you know
two 200 bucks that you had spread across
all your buy now pay later apps so it
goes on to say buy now pay later seduced
a generation with a great pitch the
firms position themselves as a
financially responsible alternative to
credit because per after pays former
executive director young people quote
don't want to be on credit if the first
rule of marketing is give people what
they want a corollary is give them what
they don't want just call it something
else so by now later they're trying to
act like no no we're not like credit
cards we're like not even really debt
we're just trying to help you spread
your payments out that's all it is but
the truth is they're just as bad if not
more predatory than any other lender any
other credit card company out there
that's out there because it is it's debt
and if you've listened to the show for
more than two minutes you know
this idea of becoming debt free having
no debt no payments does something not
only financially in your life and
mathematically but it does something
spiritually for your mental health you
sleep better at night you make different
decisions in life you maybe even can
switch jobs i mean there's so much
freedom and options and margin that
comes with living below your means and
getting out of debt